be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so having finished our video on the
history of Batman vs Superman and with a
video on the full publication history of
the Suicide Squad having already been
completed I thought it might be a good
idea to jump into the histories of the
cast from the Suicide Squad as well as
their involvement on the team and so in
this video we're going to be focusing on
Harley Quinn and what I'm hoping is that
by the end of all this you'll have a
solid understanding of her in terms of
her involvement with the Suicide Squad
and how it compares to the film however
because DC rebooted their characters in
2011 with a new 52 we're going to be
focusing on Harley's new 52 story rather
than her story prior to new 52 so those
are not relevant anymore
you
written by Amanda Connor and Jimmy Paul
me ah T the story of Harley Quinn is
told in secret origins number 4 from
2014 what we're told on this story is
that while Harley Quinn grew up in a
normal family that Harley Quinn herself
wasn't very normal as its explained to
us Harley's obsessions are manifested in
two forms her interest in the criminal
mind and by extension the act of murder
while her first crush came in the form
of a boy named Bernie Bosch this was due
more to her desire to feed off of
Bernie's experience with witnessing a
man being drowned whether than a natural
interest in Bernie as a person this is
compounded on when Bernie makes the
statement that he would actually like to
kill a woman named Bonnie Harper for the
simple reason that she had annoyed
Harley Quinn now this desire comes to
fruition when Bernie apparently commits
this act by throwing Bonnie out of his
car and into the way of a truck however
as a result of murdering Bonnie Bernie
is arrested and sent to prison where
it's revealed by Harley that he had
actually been stabbed to death now
following this the story jumps forward
following Harley Quinn's graduation from
Gotham University where she becomes a
criminal psychologist working in Arkham
Asylum her desire to analyze the minds
of the criminals within combined with
her recognition that the provided
medication creates a barrier of mistrust
between the inmates and the staff led
her to undergo an experiment requiring
her to illegally enter Arkham as an
inmate while she had a preset list of
sorts on who she wanted to interview at
the top of her list was the Joker due to
his insanity and the inability of anyone
to understand why he was so insane now
over the course of several psychological
sessions between the two a Harley
eventually finds herself falling in love
with the Joker now whether this is due
to a psychotic break in the mind of
Harley or a result of manipulation isn't
really available for authenticity since
Harley herself is technically insane but
from her perspective the Joker was able
to relate to her in a way that no one
else could and that he talks to her as
if he knows her entire life and that the
two of them are effectively destined to
be soul mates however when the warden of
the prison is
murdered and Harley's actions are
uncovered the she has a psychotic break
where her love for the Joker overrides
everything else leading her to actually
break the Joker out of Arkham Asylum
now as the story continues Harley Quinn
tells us that their relationship became
more complicated in that from Holly's
perspective the Joker completed her
while this may seem a little ambiguous
she actually goes into a little more
detail by stating that the Joker
subjected her to the same chemicals that
bleached his own skin
Harley tells us that her reaction to
this was initially fearful but because
her emotional attachment to the Joker
was now presented physically the she
felt of this newfound freedom in casting
aside her old identity provided her with
a level of fulfillment that she didn't
really have before however when she and
the joke were effectively break up
following the Joker's arrest in
Detective Comics number one followed by
the surgical removal of his face this
sends Harley on a downward spiral and
that she engages in a series of murders
on various people now following this
rampage Harley is eventually found and
captured where she's arrested and like
the rest of the team forced to work as
part of the Suicide Squad
now as part of the Suicide Squad itself
while Harley is a very effective member
of the team a herd disconnect with
reality combined with her psychotic
tendencies turn her into a character
that walks a knife's edge as a really
good example of this in Suicide Squad
number seven she effectively abandons
the team to search for the Joker's face
while she is eventually able to locate
it
she is also pursued by Deadshot in one
of the strangest moments of the series
she actually ties up Deadshot puts the
Joker's face on him and then begins
addressing Deadshot as if he were the
Joker
now while Deadshot is able to break
loose and subdue Harley this provides us
with the best example of how insane she
truly is now following this incident she
is kept on the team by Amanda Waller but
due to Harley's overall success in DC
Comics she's actually removed from the
Suicide Squad in 2013 and was provided
with her own self-titled series with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end and I
will catch you guys later peace